[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zum teil ist wenn es
in meinem heutigen video zeige ich euch
wie ihr hilfe vermehren können
eigentlich wollte ich da zucker kein
video machen und habe das einfach so
jetzt nebenher gemacht und das hat der
rat was machst du denn da sind ja ich
vermisse meine hilfe denn momentan geht
es halt keine hilfe mehr keine frische
hefe zumindest getrocknete hilfe gibt's
natürlich immer im vatikan
ich habe auch ihre hilfe eigene form
aber so langsam werden die vorräte knapp
und wenn ihr noch hier verwirft zu hause
habt könnt ihr sie vermehren und zwar
machen wir das mit hilfe eines vortrages
vortrag den mache ich so auch gerne mal
wenn ich ein hefeteig zubereitet
da bietet nämlich viele vorteile sind
man auch indirekte teigführung also
direkte teigführung heißt einfach alle
zutaten für den hefeteig in den topf
geben verkneten und dann heftig
auszubrechen funktioniert auch prima
aber wenn ihr die indirekte teig für
gemacht also mit vorteig dann habt ihr
die vorteile dass ihr zum einen lässt
backeigenschaften haben eine bessere
krume habt das gepäck bleibt länger
frisch es ist auch bei körperlicher hat
also wirklich viele viele vorteile und
ihr könnt eben weniger hefe verwenden
und eben die gz geht dann auch um
einiges schneller weil wir dann eben
schon ein vorteil gehabt und ihr für
eure hilfe einfach vermehren also
generell gilt bei hefeteig
je mehr hefe benutzt und so kürzlich die
gehzeit und die weniger hebe nutzt um so
länger müsst ihr warten aber die längere
aufgezeigt bedeutet eben auch dass es
direkte chemnitzer wird ist nicht
weniger nachhilfe aber die meisten
nehmen einfach immer einen dürfen
hilferufen von einer tram bild weil man
dann eben nur eine halbe stunde stunde
den teig aufgehen wird aber in allen
rezepten die ich auch gemacht haben
könnt ihr immer die hilfe menge
reduzieren oder eben auch erhöhen wenn
es schneller gehen soll
also ich nehme jetzt gleich einen halben
würfel hefe und daraus entsteht
vielleicht wirklich viel hilfe das
könnte wirklich super einfach zu hause
selber nach ihr nehmen dafür einfach 100
milliliter lauwarmes wasser in einem
würfel hefe 15 gramm zucker und 100
gramm weißes mehl das heißt mehr
weizenmehl 405 in ganz hell
damit funktioniert wirklich wunderbar
also ich hab ich das lauwarme wasser
die hilfe kommt jetzt dazu ich habe
jetzt aus dem gefrierfach aber ihr könnt
auch ganz frische aus dem kühlregal
nehmen
hefe nie zu lange aufheben weil dann
einfach die eigenschaften wirklich
verloren gehen lieber dann gleich
einfrieren
[Musik]
jetzt kommt da der zucker dazu
dann muss mir das schon
die arbeit ist jetzt erst mal getan denn
hier läuft jetzt ganz abgedeckt am
tatort bei etwa 28 grad mehr perfekt
aber ich habe jetzt hier auch damals
wasser gelöst und ich denke das hat dann
ungefähr auch schon die temperatur an so
abdecken
und dann dauert es so etwa je nach
temperatur 20 bis 30 minuten und kann
schneller gehen kann länger dauern
aber das volumen das wird wirklich
richtig groß als verdoppelt und
verdreifacht von 480 sogar ich mache
gerade noch aus der übrigen hälfte der
hefe einfach nochmal die gleiche menge
ihr müssten gefäßen etwas groß genug ist
weil es wirklich an volumen zunimmt
und dann werde ich das ganze gleich
aufteilen bei 28 grad ist die färbung
der hefe wirklich am besten das ist die
beste temperatur dafür und die aufgeht
temperatur hefeteig liegt so bei etwa 34
grad da geht der teig am besten auf und
ab 45 grad sterben hilfe grund wurden
das heißt im backofen stück fitter neben
ab beim backen und deswegen hefeteig nie
zu war aufgehen lassen also wirklich
immer so bei 32 34 grad ist perfekt
nicht so heiß und jetzt mama ganzen ist
dass wir schön aufgeht
[Musik]
die hilfe ist echt krass gewachsen als
aber ich habe das hier gerade eingeführt
und kann zwei minuten stehen lassen und
die ist schon wieder über gequollen hat
sich gefilmt es jetzt hier einfach ein
eiswürfel behälter ein immer so ungefähr
15 gramm kooperation
ihr könnt auch einen spritzbeutel an und
sg bisschen sauberer habe ich wollen
auch schon gemacht aber ich wollte euch
einfach zeigen wie es auch hier mit
einem lappen geht
ihr könnt auch hier aus gießen aber dann
die masse ist einfach so zählen haben
vielleicht keine kontrolle
jetzt will ich es hier ein so bis kurz
unter die kante und dann wird sofort
eingefroren
ich muss jetzt auch hier neben dran
dieses gefährt sofort einfrieren
ansonsten geht die hilfe jetzt gleich
wieder auf sie wächst einfach und lebt
und atmet er 100 fähig sein kann
herausholen und dann habe ich immer
einen hefe würfel und aber ich gucke
jetzt einfach ein paar rezepte aus nehme
ich mit in meinem experiment und dann
habt ihr hoffentlich nach diesem video
eine tolle anleitung wie ihr hilfe
selber machen kann
[Musik]
deckel drauf schnell ein pferd und jetzt
etwas gefroren ist direkt auflegen
dann wird's gleich fest also unsere hefe
und jetzt nur zeigen wie hilfe selbst
gemacht wird es natürlich langweilig ist
gleich bei euch aus also ich hier bei
der ersten produktion der wir sofort
eingefangen
super geklappt ihr seht auch einzelne
schöne hilfe wird die zweite portion ist
ein bisschen eskaliert da habe ich
einfach zu lange gewartet
aber das macht nichts ich drücke sie
einfach auch gleich trotzdem aus und
jetzt mal etwas süßem hefeteig den mache
ich musste bei hefegebäck zeit einfach
nur mein standard eic und ich mache den
normalerweise mit 500 gramm mehl
jetzt machen wir einen mit einem kilo
und für 500 gramm würde ich jetzt einen
würfel nehmen fünf kilo nämlich jetzt 2
und das ganze ist ein bisschen anders
als mit frischer hefe oder auch bei
frischer hilfe ist wirklich so oder auch
ein trockenhefe
je mehr hefe ihr verwendet um so weniger
aufgezeigt braucht ihr aber die weniger
hefe ihr benutzt und sogar körperlicher
wird der teig umso langsamer geht dann
natürlich auch auf aber er schmeckt dann
hat auch keiner
das heißt die aufgezeigt wird
wahrscheinlich etwas länger sein 1 ich
glaube die frauen aber das macht längst
kam ich noch aus
beim einfrieren
dann gebe ich jetzt einfach ein bisschen
wasser dazu zum auflesen
[Musik]
wunderbar aus und jetzt kommt im prinzip
alles andere dazu
also mädels hatte ich hier auch schon
drin und damit der hefeteig extra saftig
und schön wird nämlich pro kilo 4 eigelb
also nicht zwei ganze eier dann etwas
warme milch erhalten ein bisschen zurück
dann zucker ich glaube ich nicht mit
weniger kompetenzen
ich weiß noch nicht was ich sonst zu
bereiten wahrscheinlich seien hier
besser und viel zu kleiner teil einfach
ausprobieren und weiche butter
[Musik]
perfekt von knete jetzt den hefeteig und
lassen dann an den warmen ort auf gehen
entweder in der küchenmaschine und bei
gern stumpfe immer gruppen und gleich
probiere ich noch einem herzhaften tag
also einen pizzateig aus und sage euch
wie es geklappt hat
ich bin richtig gespannt also im prinzip
ja jetzt wie einfach mit einem vortrag
zu arbeiten ersten vortrag hergestellt
als hefe und ich schon witze drauf
[Musik]
da gab es durch nebel und da ist er
stehe ich jeden tag immer lange kneten
also in zehn minuten ist zwar schön
weich aber erhebt eben nicht das hat mir
richtig tolle konsistenz ein bisschen
kitschig ist aber dass hier gar nicht
schlimm ich habe ihn jetzt sogar zwölf
minuten geknetet juve auch liga unter
sein weicher ist jetzt ganz normal wie
immer an den teig zu einer kugel formen
auch gleich noch den und da nehme ich
jetzt auch anderen eine prüfung von
selbstgemachten hilfe denn hitze täglich
oft im kühlschrank einfach aufgeben
aufwand auch das zunächst ab so wird er
nämlich auch bekömmlicher und vor allem
kann man sich das gebaren gute aussieht
wo bist du schön damit die oberfläche
nicht trocknet und da kommt jetzt bei
mir in den backofen denn dass süßes
hefegebäck welches gleich
weiterverarbeiten
[Musik]
also normalerweise braucht er immer so
30 minuten
ich bin ich mal gespannt wie lange er
jetzt brauche ich auch gleich aber ihr
könnt ihn auch ganz einfach einpacken
und anderem warm und schön aufgehen
lassen bis er sich verdoppelt hat also
da geht man jetzt eher nicht auf die
zeit sondern eher aufs volumen mit
hefeteig sich verdoppelt hat ist ein
fall für die weitere verarbeitung jetzt
noch pizzateig da nämlich jetzt nur
einen würfel denen das ich nämlich oft
wirklich anführer nacht auf gehen also
im kühlschrank ist einfach auf 900 mio
und da ist auch einfach wieder mit
wasser auflösen
übrigens kein licht keine schlüpfen will
modus im rezepte schreiben uns eine
verbreiten modus
[Musik]
und hier einfach das fed immer zum
schluss also egal ob butter oder öl
immer nicht direkt abgegeben sondern
wirklich erst zum schluss zum trinken zu
geben
[Musik]
jetzt eigentlich euch mal weiter zeige
und zwar habe ich den süßen hefeteig im
backofen bei der schufa aufgehen lassen
und dann einfach ohne so sieht das aus
nach fünf stunden also wirklich
wunderschön und er riecht einfach total
lecker und angenehm und gar nicht nach
hebeln also echt super das ist der
pizzateig aus dem kühlschrank decken
jetzt wirklich kaum auf aber im
kühlschrank geht hefe immer langsamer
und deswegen stellt man ihnen ja auch
mein kühlschrank den dass ich jetzt
einfach über nacht im kühlschrank steht
ich probiere es einfach aus und den will
ich jetzt heute abend eigentlich auch
nicht mehr weiter verarbeiten
daher würde ich den jetzt entweder im
kühlschrank stellen und oder in die
garage
ich glaube kühlschrank weil die garage
ich glaube heute noch die zuhörer frost
also stelle ich mir einfach meinen
kühlschrank benutzers morgen früh und
dann sehen wir einfach gleich wie es
schmeckt und wie die verwendung ist aber
dass sie die chance einen sitz abdecken
und eine nacht ruhen lassen aber wie
gesagt den könnten auch direkt weiter
verwenden wenn man sieht ganz gut
dagegen richtig schön auf ist schön
locker ich bin gar nicht anfangs man
also so perfekt aussieht so richtig
schön es hat alles super geklappt guckt
mal meinen hefeteig der weit über nacht
im kühlschrank jetzt habe ich ihnen aber
schon vor zwei stunden etwa aus dem
kühlschrank raus damit einfach wieder
schön waren wir dann zur
weiterverarbeitung aber wie gesagt hätte
ich den gästen weiterfahren können der
vorteil ist
ich strahle unterricht einfach nicht
häufig normal ist er wirklich so wie man
hefe im teig zu berge stehen lässt sagt
er
dieser gar nicht dass ich jetzt ist es
geworden zwischen kühlschrank
dieser ist jetzt der süße hier verteilt
und den drittel ich jetzt und macht zum
einen kleine hilfestellung mit mätzchen
und sonders wie wachs stehen
so ein schöner tag der richter sie zuvor
aus detail konsistenz ist perfekt also
es hat echt super geklappt so einmal
dritteln
ach ist das schön so etwa war die hefe
schnecken mit nougat ich kann mir schon
auf einen blick nehmen
butter ist drin und ich jetzt hier
einfach bei niedriger stufe effekt da
nehme ich noch lukas 4 1
im sommer konnte ich sogar noch ein
bisschen kann jetzt auch schmerzen
[Musik]
ich freue mich jetzt einfach so kleine
dünne lange strenge und die lasse ich
kurz liegen so entspann sich der teig
und dann legt ihr die zwei stränge
übereinander und 14 uhr wird sie zweimal
und eine schöne noch lasse die zwei
stränge sind jetzt hier oben die
hasenohren und da unten in die öffnung
kommt dann noch das kleine städtchen
rennen
[Musik]
dann gibt es hier noch geflochtene
grenze also einfach drei stränge nehmen
und wie bei den haaren oder wie bei
freundschaftsbändchen einfach von außen
in die mitte von rechts nach links
einmal flechten
[Musik]
dann kurz entspannen lassen und hier auf
ein blech zu einem kranz legen sind hier
einfach auch die enten miteinander
verknüpfen
[Musik]
ich habe lauter 60 gramm welchen also
circa 60 gramm das wenngleich die matte
stehen
da gibt es auch ein rezept schon auf dem
kanal perfekt eingebettet perfekt
geschmolzen
ich habe ich jetzt den restlichen weiter
ausgebaut
da kommt jetzt nur wird ein ort auf ein
bisschen alle drauf ich habe es noch
nicht gesagt dass ich nun gleich
schmecken mag ich hatte nur gebucht so
einfach da sind sich alle ausgeflippt
schnecken ganz geschmolzen athletisch
der queens katrin steht der innovative
mit chris aber ich glaub ich mach gleich
noch mit chris brandt haselnüsse haase
das stück erleben das zeug dazu perfekt
gerüstete haselnüsse macht ich krieg
hunger ist sarkastisch
das kriegt man direkt was aus seinem
experiment alles entsteht so einfach mal
kurz drei verschiedene tasse es dann
noch pizza und makromolekulare wie ich
bin echt glücklich mit der hefe denn man
hat einfach mehr verarbeitungszeit die
häfen einfach dann nicht schlecht
der hefeteig perfekt kann man sie jetzt
machen wenn man die rolle da noch eine
friert dann hat man wirklich so eine
perfekte schöner schnecke
ich glaube nicht frieren sie ein ich
will dass die schnecke perfekt hat also
wirklich das ist hier so rein
richtig schön fest und dann kommen sie
im gefrierschrank und sobald ihr rolle
so ein bisschen an gefroren ist kann ich
sie ohne silikon mutter natürlich schön
in scheiben schneiden hier einsetzen
und dann habe ich schöne lukas schmecken
die sonne als können aber ein schatz ich
hab das wm experiment gemacht und es ist
gut geworden ich bin so glücklich kann
ich den kraftvoll auf hier lukas
schnecken häfen experimenten und das
finnische explodierte lukas schmecken
dann mache ich nur zu spät am kursen und
dann habe ich noch so klein ist diese
osterhäschen und heute kannst und gleich
noch pizza und stromboli frohe ostern
ich wollte nur wenn die neben werden und
jetzt werde ich so explodiert ich habe
es ja auch vermehrt genau welches von
e10 jetzt geht weiter mit
ich mache jetzt auch nicht so mäßig
sondern eher einfarbig
wir haben im frühjahr als ostern als
auch weil ich dir jetzt hier raus ich
glaube dass hebel wieder mit länger als
ich dachte ich dachte es jetzt nur zehn
minuten raus ok ich hab' ich dachte mir
kommen das zeigt auch alles noch die
dänen und hat einfach einen großen
einfach zu nehmer voll von der füllung
wie schreibe ich euch auch in die apps
einfach die natur können
[Musik]
jetzt noch eine aprikose drauf und
fertig gebracht werden
[Musik]
jetzt gibt's noch kein garantierter
hefeteig ich habe jetzt hier nur doch
noch mal eine selbstgemachte hilfe dazu
gegeben einfach dass er eben doch ein
bisschen mehr aufgeht also einem
selbstgemachten doch nicht zu sehr
spannen wirklich pro 500 am ein würfel
das passt perfekt und denen habe ich
jetzt hier bei zimmertemperatur kraft
vor allem auch um eine gern stufe also
wenn der aufnahme kriegt bisher auch
wirklich super und ich denke so wie zwei
würfen wäre es auch schön im kühlschrank
aufgegangen und jetzt mal richtig los
das heißt tomaten aus geklonten etwas
tomatenmark bibel gibt es aber auch
schon rezept laufen
und was macht die frauen schon immer aus
[Musik]
diese manchmal den vorteil dass die
kinder die zwiebel nicht sehen und
gesehen weil ich denke immer bei
selbstgemachten wenig zwiebel darüber
gemacht dass andere italiener nehmen
weil sie sehen weil die ziel oder sie
sagen sie mama auch der triebe unseres
[Musik]
guckt euch den schönen lieferte der wird
doch einfach perfekt aus ich habe jetzt
gedacht weil es alle aus dem team wieder
mit essen hat doch kein stromboli wir
machen nicht nur pizza ihr freund sich
jetzt alle 3,6 kleinere also sechs
mittellose da steig ich auch viel wie
ein vortrag durch die lange zeit einfach
besser zum kontern
[Musik]
zu den leckeren kindes bringen boden im
spannenden jetzt erweitert
[Musik]
und wenn der dreisatz die geblieben ist
dann geht das öffnen wirklich so einfach
[Musik]
jetzt gibt es hier lukas schmecken
ich denke ich macht guck mal die
perfekte anschnitt anders mega oder
[Musik]
das war mein tv video angesehen hat
alles super geklappt herz haftung doch
süß die hefe ist bei mir eine von
entweder lasst diesen behältern mit
deckel natürlich oder ihr nehmt sie
jetzt aus und füllen sie in den metall
gefäß oder andere ist verschlossen das
gefäß und ja die pizza gegessen die war
echt super lecker schmecken nicht häufig
das klappt alles wunderbar also probiert
gerne aus schreibt mir euer feedback und
ich freue mich weg die falschmeldung und
wenn ihr noch wünsche habe ideen oder
anregungen schreibt mir gerne ihr seht
wir setzen sie dann super schnell um für
euch
und ja ich wünsche euch noch richtig
schön fand und bis zum nächsten mal
sie und alle rezepte die ich hier
gemacht habe schreibe ich euch natürlich
in die app